قبل وفاته ، خضع روبن ويليامز
لاختبارات متعددة في محاولة
لمعرفة الخطأ الذي كان يعاني منه ، حيث كان
يعاني من حركات ذاكرة شديدة.
تقول أرملة ويليامز إن تشريح الجثة
كشف أن زوجها الراحل مصاب بخرف جسدي
رديء أو أن هذا هو النوع الثاني الأكثر
شيوعًا من الخرف التدريجي
بعد مرض الزهايمر وفقًا
لعيادة مايو ويسبب انخفاضًا تدريجيًا
في القدرات العقلية ، وقد يعاني الأشخاص
المصابون باضطراب الكبد من هلوسات بصرية
وتغيرات في  اليقظة والانتباه
قد يكون لديهم أيضًا علامات
لمرض باركنسون مثل العضلات الجامدة بطيئة الحركة
وصعوبة المشي والارتعاش في
الوقت الحالي لا توجد طريقة دقيقة للغاية
أو علامة بيولوجية مقبولة
لتشخيص شخص مصاب بخرف الجسم الليوي
أثناء وجوده على قيد الحياة ،
قد تزيد بعض العوامل من خطر الإصابة بمرض الكبد.
الأشخاص الذين تزيد أعمارهم عن 60 عامًا هم أكثر
عرضة للإصابة  الجنس يصيب المرض الرجال أكثر
من النساء والتاريخ العائلي ، أي شخص
لديه قريب مصاب بمرض lbd أو
مرض باركنسون يكون معرضًا لخطر أكبر
بينما لا يوجد علاج قد تتحسن بعض الأعراض
بالعلاج إذا كان لدينا
تشخيص دقيق كان من
الممكن أن نطلب رعاية متخصصة
روبن  لم يكن
علينا أن نشعر بالخوف الشديد ولن نضطر إلى إضاعة
الكثير من الوقت الثمين في
محاولة معرفة ما كان يحدث
للحظة الصحية ، أنا ماندي أذهب